yeah game already running weathers
international master Rainmaker it's it's
funny I played him really really often
but i always have white so now again
with like okay is playing them Scotch
form lights which is somewhat yeah
somewhat old-fashioned opening but it's
very solid for white and well can be
recommended if you want to want to have
a really rock solid position it's very
difficult for black to and to get
something here in order to while trying
to try to play for window at least
complicate the game it's very often
leads to draw end games yeah okay well
let's go h6 hunt this is one of those
end game sound I mentioned sorry the
phone is really take this later not sure
how to switch off the sound sorry yeah
one idea what do I'd like to do is play
night III and Bishop f5 exchanging the
the white squared bishops of course some
I don't want to allow that if possible
yeah let's check maybe maybe Bishop d7
9e three rookie aid and I'm Bishop f5
play Bishop e6 yeah something like this
as you can see on this kind of structure
is it's very very rigid okay it's not
even playing Bishop f5 but night f5 some
bits of privilege surprises me as if I
just take it should be should be very
very Josh it's got some slight chances
here to mullah tech the porn see a
button still on its own hard to imagine
how black can lose this position yeah we
should be seven I play player looking to
yeah okay but I'm Bishop c5 immediately
yeah let's play this first yeah this is
a rather typical opposition um I've
always got this counter play on on f2
and it's hard to see what white can do
to to get rid of this
yeah maybe this is this is an ID i am
trying to to get the kick up maybe i
should have played age 5 or something
right at five yeah one it's nothing
nothing serious nothing is up any look
exchange is just an instant draw and
it's out for y2 to avoid that and the
long run
come on brah offered this is completely
dead okay it doesn't want okay then
we'll yeah okay is playing on time maybe
the typical yeah stupid way to try but
this is just that I keep the the bishop
on this diagonal so you cannot play
before and he cannot get anything great
this is completely ridiculous yeah I can
also win f7 I don't mind yeah is there
some idea there's g5 some breakthrough
yeah maybe maybe there's a g5
breakthrough gras offered well thanks
game draw the eyes it's it's it's just
that I think maybe maybe you can can try
g5 at some point maybe but it looks
unlikely yeah let's go let's get to
another game this was just a just dull